هناك اصداع في السودان لهذه الكلمه خاصه
ان مبعوث البرهان دفع الله الحاج التقى
بعدد من وزراء خارجيه الدول قبل انعقاد
هذه القمه قدم لهم شرحا كافيا حول ما حدث
في السودان كلمته في هذه القمه كانت حول
بدء هذه الحرب وحول الاعتداءات التي قامت
بها قوات الدعم السريع من وجهه نظر الجيش
السوداني وكذلك الاعتداء على المقر
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه
ومقر تابع للجامعه العربيه حدد دفع الله
الحاج كثير من البنود الكثير عفوا من
النقاط التي يعتقد ان للجامعه العربيه دور
كبير في ادانه ما حدث خاصه ان الاعتداءات
كانت على بعثات دبلوماسيه عربيه هناك
اصداء في السودان لهذه الكلمه خاصه منتهى
كما اشرت انت قبل قليل كان هناك اعفاء
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو من
منصبه كنائب رئيس لمجلس السياده ربما ولو
تاخر هذا الاعفاء ولكنه يقرا مع التحركات
التي كانت للمستشار
محمد حمدان دقلو في الخارج اخرها كان لقاء
له مع رئيس دوله جنوب السودان وعقد مؤتمر
الصحفيا هناك فبالتالي هذا هذه الاصداء
تاتي
للوساطه التي تتم
للانتهاكات التي تقال من قبل الحكومه
السودانيه ممثله في وكيل وزاره الخارجيه
وهو ايضا مبعوث البرهان وهناك ايضا
مطالبات منتهى من المجتمع المحلي السوداني
بضروره ان يكون هناك اسهام اكبر لوقف هذه
الحرب ووقف اطلاق النار من قبل الجانبين
خاصه ان التوقيع الذي عقد في جده حتى
اللحظه لم ينفذ عمليا باعتبار ان هناك
كانت بنود متعلقه بضروره الابتعاد عن
مناطق السكان والمناطق المدنيه وحتى
اللحظه لم يتم ذلك لذلك هناك مطالبات
لاكمال هذه المباحثات التي تنعقد الان في
جده في مرحلتها الثانيه